you're looking at pictures of the white
house where it's been
six days since president trump made any
public comments about the coronavirus he
is staying out of sight
while he challenges the election results
president-elect
biden speaks with democratic and
republican governors today
in a virtual meeting to discuss the
pandemic as ed o'keefe reports
the next president had an emotional and
revealing meeting yesterday with medical
workers
i have not been tested yet and i have
been on the front lines in the icu since
february
you're kidding me president-elect joe
biden virtually coming face-to-face with
the crisis he set to inherit in january
as he heard directly from nurses on the
front lines of the coronavirus pandemic
there is something seriously wrong when
nurses
have to take to the streets to beg for
protection
in the middle of a pandemic i'm sorry
i'm so emotional it's just you got me
emotional
biden said that the trump
administration's refusal to certify his
victory
means he cannot yet coordinate with
federal agencies responding to the
pandemic
meaning the distribution of a vaccine
could be delayed
we've been unable to get access
to the kinds of things we need to know
about
the depth of the stockpiles we know
there's not much at all
as the virus ravages the country
president trump remains out of public
view
and made no mention of the pandemic
instead he spent the day once again
tweeting
baseless and unfounded accusations of
voter fraud
his tweets come as a new poll finds that
while 7 in 10 americans as a whole
agree mr biden won the election when it
comes to republicans
nearly seven in ten say they're
concerned that the election was rigged
the president's campaign continues to
spend time and money trying to reverse
the election results
securing a recount in two counties in
wisconsin where mr biden won by more
than 180
000 votes meanwhile today the
president-elect is set to speak with
nine
democratic and republican governors
about the pandemic
mr biden says he'll keep pushing state
leaders for stricter
coveted restrictions so one of the
things i'm going to be doing is ask
thanking the governor has already moved
but calling on
all the leaders in the states to have
mandatory masking
testing tracing social distancing
and just as many americans are adjusting
their thanksgiving day plans the
president elected yesterday that his
family is also significantly scaling
back
usually they head to nantucket island
and massachusetts aides wouldn't confirm
that that's the plan but the
president-elect said
or seem to suggest that they would be
staying here in delaware instead
heeding the suggestions of the cdc that
people scale back their holiday plans
tony all right well sometimes the only
thing harder than seeing family for the
holidays is not seeing family for the
holidays which will be the case in many
households
appreciate it ed